[Music]
it was under 1,000 apprehensions the day
before that was a relatively good number
and if it was above 1,000 was a
relatively bad number and I was going to
be in a bad mood the whole day I know
that a th000 overwhelms the system I
cannot begin to imagine what 4,000 a day
looks like so we are truly in a
crisis that was Obama era DHS secretary
Jay Johnson in 2019 when 4,000 border
crossings per day seemed high but under
President Biden the daily migrant
encounters have surged to
12,000 this week the highest total for a
single day on record that's 12,000 in a
day and Pete I think it's important to
point out 10,000 of that 12,000 came
between ports of Entry between not
through a dedicated Port of Entry uh
imagine what J Johnson would say about
12,000 I mean he was saying 1,000 is a
lot 4,000 breaks the system what does
12,000
in one day do better understand how bad
this crisis has become we're going to go
off thewall and see how it affects
multiple locations across the country
well let's start in your neck of the
woods in Texas I want to point out that
these numbers are from CBP they don't
reflect November just the month of
October with early numbers yeah there
there are a bit down from last year but
the numbers are still staggering when
you look at it broken down by ports of
Entry by border sectors actually 22,000
in El Paso
38,000 in Del Rio uh Rio Grand Valley
RGV
32,000 um in this is a single day
Encounters in Del Rio and again these
are encounters meaning they encounter a
border patrol agent they claim Asylum
they're here illegally but they claim
they're under threat what other
countries did they pass through where
they could have claimed Asylum we don't
know uh and then you've got the Goda
ways and the known goway some images
from this week from Eagle Pass Texas I
just don't see a lot of women and
children in that group
no I mean this is what an explosion of
military age males across all of these
sectors meanwhile Congressman um max
Frost Maxwell Frost Democrat said okay
listen though you got to put this into
context think about what was happening
in the early 1900s think about Ellis
Island this is not new for our country
we're a country that accepts people
especially refugees I always encourage
people to look back into the the history
of Ellis Island we were processing much
more people than we do now such a long
time ago with worst technology and so
we're we're able to do this we'll take
sounds so smart yeah no let's take you
up on that we'll compare it to Ellis
Island yeah been there been through we
did something on Fox and Friends we
visited it most 1900 a day is the max
usually or average of what went through
Ellis Island between 1900 and 1914 right
so he's suggesting it would happened you
know way more back then and of course
that's a formative period in our
nation's history we're all familiar my
grandfather came through Ellis Island
we're all very familiar with immigrants
coming legally to the United States
through Ellis Island but Maxwell Frost
says it was much more 1900 a day well
here's what's happening right now at our
Southern border almost 8,000 a day
Crossing and like you said orderly log
books identification health checks they
were checking on allegiances in
countries of origin in a far more
meaningful way than we are today and it
was a fourth effectively of what we're
seeing on our Southern border now we
talked about Texas let's move to Arizona
there's a lot of Focus right now on
what's happening in Arizona take a look
at the border Encounters in that state
17,500 in a single week that was last
week in November Pete so why might you
see it in Arizona in the winter because
these are the months of the year when
it's tenable to try to cross uh in
Arizona which in the hottest parts of
the summer months is is impossible
55,000 border encounters so far again
this is one month because we're not even
reflecting the month of November yet so
these are dated numbers but we know
they're going to go Much Higher by the
way up 141% but to Pete's point of being
dated because we know what's happening
right now yeah in lukeville Arizona just
staggering now it's not just Arizona
it's not just uh Texas you also got a
Malibu California will where boats are
are are washing up on shore of illegals
try to find another route yeah uh you
know this is Malibu California
um we we brought you the story from
roughly a week ago of one of these boats
a a a panga boat high-sided High bow
boat um another one aore this week with
migrants jumping out of an overturned
boat making their way up the beach and
into Malibu yeah well like every like
every other part where do they go next
we don't know but most of them get a
plane ticket to fly somewhere in 5,000
bucks and a phone and we'll see in 5
years for a court appearance that's not
going to happen how about the northern
border as well let's just keep going
around around every aspect of our
country everything's up so fiscal year
2023 that's the past year encounters at
the northern border up too yeah I mean
you've seen every single one of these
has climbed but but the gray shows the
climb month over month for this year but
look at it compared to 2021 this is the
blue line and you can see by the end of
the year you're looking at
3,698 versus now almost 19,000 oh the
beginning of Joe Biden's policies oh
we're getting a sense that it's pretty
uhoh better better be time to take even
more Advantage what will 2024's fiscal
year look look like I shudder to think
yeah not just the southern border right
there from Washington to Maine it's
happening all across our country and
particularly acutely since 2021 that's
the scope of this catastrophe and this
is why speaker Johnson's saying this is
a hill we want we're going to die on on
Capitol Hill is the actual enforcement
of immigration law which has been
just tossed out the window I'm Steve
Ducey I'm Brian kilme and I'm Angley
Airhart and click here to subscribe to
the Fox News YouTube page to catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis